Clear inflame a good anti-inflammatory supplement for general pain
Yes, so the clear inflame I think is the best single-shocked anti-inflammatory that we have
Because it's a broad spectrum
flavonoid meaty that it has tumeric, baswellia
rosemary, corsetin, I don't know, so several other things in it. So it's got a broad spectrum of the
flavonoids that are anti-inflammatory
Another are there are other
possible anti-inflammatory supplements like the limit list, the aloevia limit list, which is a banal in supplement, which is
highly anti-inflammatory, but it's only got that one thing in it, but some people have used that and
Replaced taking an anvil, you know, they were taking an anvil every day for their pain, and now they just take that and
It solves their problem, but from a general
broad spectrum
perspective the clear inflame is probably the best product we have for pain
Now understand you have pain from cancer that is, you know, fairly high on the pain scale level.
The natural flavonoids or the betelins probably aren't going to do the trick. So if you are currently taking, you know,
You know, multiple advilts during the day and tile it all or you're currently on a
Prescription pain medication, the chance that you're going to have
You know, be able to get off of that by going on a flavonoid is slim. Now, I will say that I've had people on the clear inflame and they're on like
5 a day and then
That's a negative because there's a lot at each capsule. You got to take a lot of capsules.
Because there's a lot of different things at each capsule. You have to take a lot of capsules to get at a real
Treatment dose, but you're not taking, you know, an opening six bonds, you know, it's all in one bottle, which is a nice benefit.
But I've had people taking 60 days and it's not touching it and they move up to 9 a day and it's like, oh my gosh, my pain's gone.
So you've got to play with that dose and
How do I know if this is going to work for me? Well, you don't unless you try it.
Now the clear inflame is, you know, we originally got that private label for inflammation in the brain and you know, if you watch my brain inflammation video, you'll find that all the research on brain inflammation and microglial primate and brain having neural antibodies to upper motor neuron
tissue, we need brain tissue, the only thing in all the research that decreased brain inflammation was the flavonoids.
So that is, I mean, to prevent, you know, to prevent Alzheimer's to prevent, you know, any early dimension to prevent Parkinson's clear inflame is a key product.
So it's a product that I take on a regular basis and you know, it's, it's, it can help beyond just pain.
So hopefully that helps.